>> KAY: So, I'd like to take a little bit
of time now to see if we can look at a few
of these cool extensions that have been made
already. And I'm really happy to be able introduce
somebody that we've been working with closely
in the community from pretty early on. So,
Colin from Xmarks, come on up and let’s
see your extension.
>> BLECKNER: Thanks, guys. I'm Colin. I'm
here with Will. We’re Software Developers
for Xmarks. One of our main products is a
Cross Browser Extension that synchronizes
your Bookmarks between different computers
and browsers. And we're happy to be here today
talking about one of our recent projects,
Xmarks for Chrome. We'll start with this quick
demo of Xmarks in action. You can access our
main UI from the Xmarks icon on the top-right.
As you can see, we're currently synchronizing
successfully. And from this page we can also
access some of our other local settings. Xmarks
icon also gives us a shortcut to my.xmarks.com.
This Website gives you online access to your
Bookmarks from any computer as well as some
of our more advanced online features. And
since we're already synchronizing, you can
see the bookmarks in those browser that match
up of what you see here in the Bookmark bar
for Chrome. So, to show Xmarks in action,
Will is actually going to delete one of his
Bookmarks on our website. That means the next
time we sync in Chrome, that deletion will
come down and we’ll move it in Chrome, too.
So, if you go to the Xmarks icon and hit “synchronize
now,” look at that synchronize go, and when
it finishes, that Bookmark should also get
removed from Chrome. That's taking a little
second. There you go. The Bookmark is gone
there, too. Similarly, if we were to add a
Bookmark in Chrome, or move things around
and then synchronize after that, that change
will go back to our servers and from there,
out to any other computers and browsers running
Xmarks. As a software developer, there are
a couple of things that I'm excited about
in Chrome. The first is that everything is
written in HTML and JavaScript. This makes
it really easy for us to put over our existing
extensions. Xmarks for example has a lot of
client side code. And we're able to pour it
pretty much all of our core sink code to Chrome
without any changes at all. And we didn’t
just happened to get lucky in this one case.
A couple of weeks ago, I was looking at search
tabs. This is another Xmarks extension that
helps users discover similar sites while they’re
searching. I got it up and running in Chrome
in less than a day and there's something like
50 Chrome specific lines of code. Everything
else was shared Cross Browser Code. This is
a huge win for us and not just because we
get things up and running so fast, more importantly
for me, it means that maintaining that code
in those extensions is going to be a lot more
manageable for us in the future. The second
thing I'm excited about is that the extension
API has access to HTML5 features. When I first
started working on Xmarks for Chrome, one
of the biggest issues I had was figuring out
how to store information on a user’s computer.
We store a lot of data locally to help speed
up our sink process, but the extension API
doesn't, you know, have any file I/O code
or support. However, HTML5 has things like--it's
got local storage in SQL data bases. And so,
I was able to take our file I/O code and rewrite
that using this HTML5 features, and everything
else runs smoothly on top of that. Overall,
I'm pretty excited to be writing extensions
for Chrome. I think that the extension API
itself really promotes Cross Browser development
and that's going to make it a lot easier for
us to build and maintain our extensions. So,
thanks again, guys. And up next we could got
Jeff talking about Google Translate.
>> JEFF: Hi. I'm Jeff from the Google Translate
Team. Before I begin, I wanted to just give
a quick shout out to Jerry Tieng (ph). The
Engineer who developed the translate extension.
Unfortunately, he couldn't be here. So, I'll
be giving the demo instead. So, let's say
you're searching for the top French news stories,
and start by going to google.fr. Since the
content of this page is in French but my browser
language is an English, the translate extension
will pop up and prompt me to see if I--whether
or not I want to translate this page into
English. Since I don't speak French, you know,
I'll go ahead and click on translate. And
voila, the page is now instantly translated
into English so I can read and understand
it. So now I'm looking for news, so now, you
know, I'm able to find news since it’s in
my language. I'll go ahead and click on the
news link. And since this next page is also
in French, the translate extension will immediately
translate the page as well. So, if the translate
extension looks similar or the same as the
Website translator gadget that's on Google
Translate, well, the reason why is because
it's the same code. Developing the translate
extension was quick and easy because we are
able to leverage the existing code that we've
created. In order to reuse this code though
we had to propose or re-propose to extensions--two
functions to the extensions API. The first
one, detects language, automatically detects
the language of the page and returns it to
us. We use this to determine whether or not
we should prompt and show the standard to
the user to translate the page. The second
function executes script allows us to inject
our existing gadget code into the page and
tell the browser to execute it. So in summary,
developing the translate extension for Chrome
was extremely easy and quick because we are
able to reuse and leverage existing code.
And if there's a function that you need that
doesn't yet exist, you can propose it to the
Chrome team and once approved, you can work
with them to get it implemented. And next,
I'll--Adam from eBay will share with you his
experience.
>> ADAM: Thanks. It's great to be here. You
know, it's been a long time since we started
eBay as just a Website. Ever since we first
launched our public APIs in 2000, we really
viewed eBay as an E-commerce platform, where
our customers can buy and sell wherever they
are, really creating a new and much more robust
site than what we had before. And we sort
of called this policy “eBay anywhere.”
We want our customers whether they're using
a mobile device, whether on eBay.com, whether
they're using a desktop gadget to experience
eBay wherever they are. And that's why development
environment, such as, Google Chrome are so
important to us because we know that many
of our customers do use Chrome. And we want
them to have fantastic experience when they
do so. Now, I'm going to give a quick demo
of an extension that one of our team has been
working on. Just like the Translate Team,
Diane Forch [PH], she couldn't be here today
because they are in London. But I'm going
to do a demo on their behalf. So, again, it
doesn't matter. You could be on a page, you
know, searching news at google.fr. And you
say, “Hey, I want to check to see what's
going on eBay.” And so, we have a menu right
here and you can go and click and find out
what's going on. I'm already signed in, so
you can see I’m sort of watching a couple
items: Lego Star Wars, new sneakers. I’m
going to say, “Oh, maybe I want to get that.”
You know, but wanting more information, you
know, you can sort of click and see more and
sort of just little fade, it moves over, and
you can see all the information you want to
know about the item, or and, actually, if
you want to, you can go and place more, go
and actually place the bid. Alternately, this
is sort of what we call “my eBay interface.”
And so, those are active items. We also have
ended items, right? These are all the things
that I've been watching or buying or lost.
And if I say, “Hey, I want to try to find
that. Hey, what was that item that I just
won? ”Well, then I can just sort of click
here, pull up a little menu and do a filter
in place just to find the item that I won,
and there it appears, right? So now, it's
changed so I should leave a bid to lead feedback.
So, everything is sort of in context, in place,
really easy to filter it. Of course, we also
have the ubiquitous search box, so I could
look for kittens, for example, but, you know,
we actually have policy. You can’t sell
kittens on eBay, so. So, I won't do that because
Lord knows what might show up. Sorry, do it
yourself. Anyway, so, once again, we really
enjoyed, it’s really a fun experience writing
the extension. The integrated development
environment, which you sort of saw earlier,
made it much easier for us to build and debug
it. Also, we have existing extensions for
other browsers and similar to what you also,
again, heard before, it was very easy for
us to port over our code. All the business
logic, this one straight over, and then we
had to go and tackle the UI that we just have
to do that for Chrome, and that made, again,
keeping all of our code basis in synch nice
and easy. In fact, that's one of the things
that we really took advantage of when we were
doing the design with the HTML5 and CSS3 to
do what we really wanted, because Chrome has
a different approach as you learned. More
minimal approach to user interface and we
had to figure out how do we tackle that problem,
you know, while we're miming Webby and also
eBay. And so, those were really great. I sort
of thinking about how to handle it and also
we want with a sort of a mobile approach,
because they both have in some ways that are
restrained, real stay, and smaller UI that
needs to get done. And so, when we tackle
that, we said, “Hey, we can take advantage
of CSS3 to do rounded corners and gradients
for the background.” Things that we had
done before, but we had to put image hacks
and things we didn’t like. So this was much
cleaner and really simplified our presentation
logic. Likewise, with HTML5, we will to go
much more or beyond the fact that we have
cookies, right? So with eBay, there are a
lot of user preferences, there's a lot of
data for each of the items that you can be
watching up to 200. In this case, we were
able to use the Name Value Pair Database for
all of our preferences. We've able to use
the SQLite database to store all the items
and made it very for us to really keep all
the information right here and improve the
speed and efficiency, which is, again, something
that we really want to make sure our customers
experience. So overall, we really had a fantastic
time with working with the Chrome Team and
we really want to thank them for all the support
that they've given us. The best part from
my standpoint is when we built this extension,
everything we saw here those are our public
APIs. We don't have to make any changes to
our own APIs to implement this. So, any developer
whether it’s eBay or anyone in this room
or anyone in the Internet, can go and build
that right now. And so, we really hope that
developers will see this as a great opportunity
for them to use Chrome as a platform to extend
and great fantastic extensions for our community.
So, if anybody wants to talk to me, I'll be
out of here later. And so, now I'm going to
hand it over to Nick from Google.